I talked about Muslims we have a problem
nobody else wanted to mention the
problem I brought it up I took a lot of
heat we have to have a temporary
something because there's something
going on that's not good
he continues to put out this fiction
that there's widespread systemic
discrimination against Muslim Americans
we need to have strong positive
relationships in the Islamic communities
in this country so they will identify
and report this activity especially
mosques this is a president who in the
wake of Paris in the wake of San
Bernardino will not even use the words
radical Islamic terrorism much less
focus on defeating the enemy these are
good law-abiding hard-working people
what they need is our cooperation in our
understanding they do not need just
broadsides against it because of the
religious faith a prize